Ian can rake a lawn and bag the leaves
in 5 hours keiondre can rake the same
lawn and bag the leaves in 3 hours
working together how long would it take
them to rake the lawn and bag the leaves
so let's think about it a little bit so
this e in can rake along and bag the
leaves in 5 hours so for E and I for Ian
he can for 1 lon
one lawn he can do one lawn in one lawn
in five hours one lawn in five hours we
could have also written this is five
hours per lawn but we'll see that
writing it this way is more useful
because it's actually a rate because
this is the same thing as one over five
lawns lawns per hour or 1/5 of a lawn
per hour that's the rate at which en can
rake a lawn at 1/5 of a lawn per hour
now let's do the same thing for kyandre
keiondre and this actually probably
shouldn't be plural 1/5 lawns 1/5 of a
lawn so let me just erase that s right
there 1/5 of a lawn per hour now let's
do the same thing for kyandre keiondre
can rake the same lawn and bag the
leaves in 3 hours
so for kyandre keiondre can for 1 lon
I'll assume it's a boy's name he can do
it in 3 hours in 3 hours or if we were
to write it as a rate this is 1/3 1/3 of
a lawn 1/3 of a lawn per hour now let's
think about what the combined rate is so
let's say if we have en Plus keiondre en
+ keiondre what's going to be there
combined
what's going to be their combined rate
well they tell us they tell us that
working together how long would it take
them to rake and bag the leaves so let's
let let's let T be how long it will take
them together how long it will take
together so that's how long they would
take together and if we say T is how
long
take together then we could say that
combined they will do one lawn they will
do one lawn in every t hours of resuming
T is in hours for every t hours or as a
rate their combined rate is going to be
one over T one teeth of a lawn
one teeth of a lawn per hour one over T
lawns per hour so that's their combined
rate so here we have the rate of en and
the rate of chiandra keiondre and the
combined rate so the combined rate is
going to be the sum of each of their
rates if he can do 1/5 of a lawn per
hour and he can do 1/3 of a lawn per
hour their combined rate is going to be
1/5 of a lawn per hour plus 1/3 of an
hour because in an hour he'll do 1/5 and
he'll do 1/3 so you'll add those two
together to figure out how much they can
do in an hour so their combined rate is
going to be 1/5 lawn per hour and I
won't write the unit's here just because
it gets redundant 1/5 lawn per hour
could right over here plus 1/3 lawn per
hour for keiondre plus 1/3 of a lawn per
hour for Kandra that's going to be their
total rate which is 1 over T lawns per
hour which is 1 over T lawns per hour
and now we just have to solve for T and
we'll know the total number of hours it
will take them so let's do that so to do
that we just have to add 1/5 plus 1/3
well we can have a common denominator of
15 so this is the same thing as 3 over
15 plus 5 over 15 plus 5 over 15 is
going to be equal to 1 over T 1 over T
and then we have a common denominator
now so three plus five is eight so this
is going to be 8 over 15 I'll go over
here now so now we have three plus five
is eight over 15 is equal to one over T
1 over T if we want to solve for T we
could take the reciprocal of both sides
so if we flip the left side we get 8
over we get 15 over 8 15 over 8 and if
we flip the right side we get T over 1
or just T so it'll take them 15 over 8
hours or if we want that in kind of a
way that we can think about it a little
bit better 15 over 8 so T is equal to 15
over
eight hours 15 over eight and I should
say 15 over eight hours per lawn this
whole time here we had lawns per hour
this was lawns per hour
this was lawn per hour and this was here
as well lawns per hour when we flip it
and become hours it becomes hours per
lawn so that's exactly what we want but
15 over 8 is the same thing as 1 and 7/8
hours and 7/8 of an hour we can get a
calculator out get our calculator out if
we have 60 minutes in an hour times 7 8
we get 50 2.5 minutes so this is equal
to our answer combined it will take them
1 hour 1 hour and 52 point 5 minutes and
52 point 5 minutes per lawn or to do
this lawn right over here the lawn in
question hopefully found that useful